hey guys how's Leo and so I'm really
excited because today I am at NFL
Network Studios and I'm about to partake
in my first NFL fantasy league draft and
I'm so excited because I actually got a
few good lucks from this is the most
must-see WWE Superstar of all time tomb
is giving you the greatest advice you'll
ever get in your entire life just look
at anything I do on Twitter and then
you'll be perfect you'll be the most
must see and you will be awesome just
like me now I would like to introduce
you to squad goals fantasy football
league guys I need you where's my squad
I thought we were squad squads going up
whatever today this is Bailey this is
Stephanie this is Jenna and we're about
to do this draft are you guys ready go
ready yes so do you guys have some
tactics that you want to go into doing
this whole thing this will draft I'm
gonna use the rankings and what it tells
me a bit I'm gonna use the Patriots
let's go go team oh my gosh no we're not
ready yet oh my god I hope you're not
ready cuz I'm all on we're not ready
well I still can't get in my chair are
you trying to distract me no exactly
yeah this is a tactic so I should
probably pick Tom Brady right actually
hurt me if you guys haven't noticed that
maybe just to make sure
oh no I absolutely clicked him not at
all
okay since I'm a huge Steeler fan I'm
gonna take Ben have it with Belle I do
totally like the first tip that I've
read it's like don't drop the quarter
back first
what's up Justin hey listen don't do
what I did
don't draft a quarterback early reach
for the people you really like whether
it's because they're cute or they're
great at football all right you're
learning it gets us to Penn this might
be here sighs I saw Ben I was like yo
what's up hey it's totally fine
Brady Bunch on the clock Brady Bunch
it's a wonder you all right I did it a
belt represent I'm sorry we see Steph
has a note she had no she's very
official this is getting mushy I have
notes but they're in my head like don't
take a quarterback first in full
disclosure that I won my weight loss I
didn't know I should have prepped me Ron
it's my turn mr. crane so what I like is
you can go through and pick like the
2015 projections you can also go back to
the 2014 so I think my tactic is going
to be why don't you take another
quarterback no I'm gonna say Barry in
the posture okay Oh Mike just updated me
said fYI the guy you just picked us out
for half the season well this is why you
have to do your research you tell you
he's in her fantasy oh goodness I feel
like I should pick a quarterback but not
yet I did
we are partway through our draft I think
everything is going quite it's quite
swimmingly actually Oh superswim you
know I've got a whole squad of Justin's
and I'm pretty pumped
oh yeah do you want him I went with the
Eagles defense all right so I'm
switching my phone because you guys seem
to be doing that's pretty easy too so
okay I'm on I'm on the clock at two
minutes oh my gosh oh okay
who we gonna pick done my team is four
picks away
next up Brady Bunch oh my god I just did
a draft with a bunch of my celebrity
pals
yeah I'm syan filming this is amazing
yeah so let's see we got Jerry O'Connell
I just amazed WWE this is so cool
Maurice jones-drew Michelle Beadle Molly
brunette and then Terrell Davis too by
the way is fantasy superstar yeah there
you go you can wear that way you ride
your little ego doll I was born I know
right here wait on a QB yeah I needed
this before we started okay but right
here it says no research needed all
right so that's it for our fantasy draft
I had so much fun and I was actually
quite surprised at how easy it was it
was really easy that was my first time
and I was expecting it to be a lot
harder but it wasn't at all our first
fantasy football league in NFL Network
Studios this is amazing even they let us
in the studio they let us in you're
gonna gave me a helmet 34 now this is
great so if you guys want to join a
league and make one of your own you can
check out NFL comm slash fantasy so if
you guys do join send me some really fun
team names that you guys have decided to
name your teams
my name is team iJustine I can change it
that can change it oh wait you guys
should tell me what I should name my
team so leave me some comments about
that leave me some comments about who
your favorite team is
and don't judge my team please it's all
for fun it is a my Johnston throws up
they're gonna do actually I didn't come
actually in it to win it
I think I'm in it to win it too but I
think you're gonna be surprised that I
might actually win we'll see you guys in
the next video bye
wish us luck I'm gonna win I'm gonna win
I can't believe I'm gonna win this might
be the best fantasy football d right
here our name is squad goals my tactic
for this is basically just to win or we
have Bailey I'm Jenna Justine
Stephanie and yeah we're gonna go drop
some players